So before we go further, I'll just
remind you again of Bayes Rule.
We looked at this last time.
The straight Bayes Rule is that
we can say that p of x, given z,
the p of the state given the
measurement, can be written this way.
This is the likelihood.
All right?
This is the total probability of z.
This, that's our prior
before the measurement.
That's our belief, if you will,
of, of, of what the value was.
Okay?
So, what's important here to realize is,
once I get the measurement.
Somebody gives you the measurement.
You drove to, to to,
to Measurements-R-Us, and
you picked up your measurement.
You didn't know which measurement
they were going to give you, and
there's a probability that they'll
give you all these different mea.
Once they give you a measurement,
the probability of having got
that measurement is done.
It, it, it is whatever it was.
It's not going to change.
So what that allows us to do
is to sort of replace that,
by this, normalization factor.
Right?
It's some value.
Or another way of saying this,
is that p of x, given z,
is proportional to p of z, given x.
All right, times the prior.
So if I had a whole bunch of different
possible x's, and I only had this value,
okay, for p of x, given z,
they have to sum to one.
So what I could do is I could just
take the sum of all of those,
whatever they were, and then divide
this value by that, divide by that sum,
and I would be back to a real,
renormalized probability density.
All right?
That's why we write it as this Eta and
we talk about this proportion.
And, in fact,
next time when we do particle filtering,
you'll see that what we do is, we if we
sample all these x's, we multiply them
by their likelihoods and we get all
these values, but they don't sum to one.
So what we have to do is take this,
take all the sum, sum them up,
then divide each of those by that
sum and it'll sum up to one again.